i don't think it's going to kill is it
the laser almost here we go but that
thing is
oh my god oh my god
starting off at number 10 we have rang
chu pulling off the
unbelievable at the tekken world tour
finals 2018.
over the course of 2018 rang xu made a
name for himself as
the panda king taking what was widely
seen as a bad character
and propelling himself to the game's
greatest stage
but after being knocked down to the
losers bracket by knee
some had their doubts that rang chu
could make it all the way
but that's when ranks you got the run
back oh the block don't punish
oh seven seconds left on the clock can
he kill
oh what are you doing what is that
immediately huge
mistake should not have played so many
characters perhaps
the final hurdle between rang chu and
the crown was kudans
who had been a thorn in rang xu's side
on the tournament circuit that year
it was time to answer the question that
had once only been asked in jest
could a panda player really rule the
world
be careful if one more he can hand it
here cue dance
we have a animal of a champion here
it doesn't matter if you actually watch
anime
we all know how it goes enemies become
friends
allies join forces friendship always
wins and villains are
sent to the shadow realm oblivion
the point is these kinds of larger than
life storylines
often happen in esports too sometimes
they can even be more anime than anime
itself
you'll see what i mean i'm danny burke
here today for the score esports and
this is the top 10
anime arcs in esports
at number nine we have the moment that
the power of friendship
took c9 to the world's playoffs
[Applause]
the final day of world's 2014 group
stage started well for cloud9 with a win
over the 0-5 kaboom esports from brazil
a few more shots coming in focus onto
the nexus
and it is going to be cloud nine coming
up with a victory over kaboom
c9 now had to beat the group favorites
imagine white shield
to force a tiebreaker between c9 majin
and alliance for their shot out of
groups
that is the tiebreaker would happen if
alliance beat kaboom as expected
but kaboom did not read the script
and i can't believe it
take the game over alliance
kaboom's unlikeliest of victories wasn't
enough to save
their tournament but crucially it opened
a door for cloud9
it was a one-team spirit bomb but it
took c9
all the way
[Music]
number eight entry is a story that needs
no introduction for dota 2 fans
it's eg's comeback at the international
six seventeen minutes into game one of
the upper bracket semi-finals
ehome had already taken down all of eg's
outer turrets
things were looking grim with mega
creeps inside their base the comeback
looked impossible but like the great
anime protagonists they were
eg never gave up
[Applause]
they hold mega creeps incoming but evil
geniuses will stand strong for now
against the home
the spaceless boy though in the back
he's now going to go for all the tickles
he may be activated and now he's going
to run himself away universe 7. he's
backing
[Applause]
up
[Applause]
the impossible
it was the greatest comeback in ti
history and
is at least deserving of its own ova if
you ask me
at number seven is the death of the
unkillable demon king
for a while faker's name meant victory
by mid-2017
after winning three of the past four
worlds his dominance in league of
legends seemed to have
no end in sight sk telecom have overcome
every challenge they are the undisputed
best team in the world his team skt were
a dynasty
in every sense of the word but at worlds
2017
one european squad took them to their
limit five
games in trying to avoid elimination and
they have done so
sk telecom t1 will be your second team
in the semifinals
claiming victory over misfits gaming it
seemed the unkillable demon king
really could bleed by their own
standards skt had
practically limped into the final where
they faced a samsung galaxy team that
had only dropped
one game in the knockout stage the skt
dynasty is over all hail the new kings
samsung galaxy your 2017
world champions it took years to build
up their kingdom
and only three games to bring it
crashing down
moving on to number six we have ana's
incredible
underdog story in the early stages of
his career many in the dota community
used to think ana wasn't the most
impressive player despite big wins like
the 2016 boston major
he struggled to stay consistent as seen
by og's early ti7
exit the end is nine gg
lgt slay the beast
they move on by 2018 he had
enough ana announced he was taking a
break while he was gone
og grew desperate two of their best
players had left
and no one could replace them no one it
seemed
but ana he was out of the hyperbolic
time chamber
just in time for ti8 and what a return
it was
and is still alive the flame guard keep
it in fight again the slider fist
cuts down a second double kill ferrana
chalice surrounded by seven under here
in the trees
oh gee get the
[Applause]
after that incredible win ana took a
break
again only to return for ti9 the next
year
and win it all for a second time in a
row
if that's not a comeback worthy of an
anime series spin-off
we don't know what is
moving on to number five we have
takedow's epic rivalry with diego
the two have long been among the most
celebrated players
to ever grace street fighter and for
fans their rivalry was the stuff of
legend think goku and vegeta amuro and
char shinji and his dad by 2018
tokido was a decorated champion but
there was one hurdle he had never
overcome beating diego in a first 10.
[Applause]
said it all two years later though
destiny brought the pair together again
at the topanga championship 2020 this
time
it was different
[Music]
his head dropped in his hands as the
world watched the ending
to a most incredible street fighter
story
at the number four spot we have a
miracle run
truly worthy of anime arc status until
2018 north america had never won
a cs go major and a lot of people
weren't expecting it to happen
any time soon get the pain over with for
now is automatic again tries to read
himself but olaf meister wants in on the
action
and it looks like a deflated team here
for cloud9
the boston major came and the hopes for
cloud9 were
dashed early on with an 02 start in
groups
sometimes though when your back's
against the wall like this
the only way is forward stewie2k anko
straight up refused to be another n a
sob story
stewie versus kenny the smell of gunfire
and freedom in the air and stewie
picking up that kill
and cloud niner in the semi finals clown
nine in a one versus four
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds
and cloud9 are in the grand finals of a
major tournament
guardian waits patiently as cloud9 sets
the push up
oh oh it's happened they made it work
clown nine are your elite major
[Applause]
champions
our number three now we have a very
anime story of how your greatest enemy
can become
your strongest ally over one and over
two
dominated the early halo scene but on
the other side of the map
was zios a pillar of the scene who they
defeated
many times over one moving the black
carbine side
gets it all the way to his base there's
no one there's strong side
in position to make it alive and here we
go
strong sides moving
and formed ffa alongside three of the
best individual players of the time
with the sole purpose of dethroning the
ogres when they finally faced after mlg
atlanta 2004
the hype of their showdown really
delivered
six people basically get into a gunfight
it's 49
49 and then no one knows who the killed
anyone
and it just credits roll the crowds like
like it didn't pop up like red team one
blue team one like
none of that should happen it just
rolled and then bam
stk lost after another loss to ffa at
their next event the defeated ogre twins
had the last laugh
by poaching two of ffa's players walshy
and killer n
the fusion dance paid off the new team
final boss became
the dominant halo team of their era and
you know what they say
if you can't beat them well
at number two we have albus knox luna
demanding respect from the world
being underdog doesn't mean being a
loser that's all
they were a wild card team from a minor
region thrown
into a group at worlds 2016 with the rox
tigers
clg and g2 so expectations
were low but albus knocks through
everyone for a loop
dixie supposed to run for his life but
look at that accelerated shot boss it's
a double kill for kira
and help is knocked they're pushing clg
the queue
on top spin he's been worked as well
elvis knox albus knocks were tied with
the rox tigers for first in their group
as the pair faced off for a final time
if there was
any doubt still surrounding them this
game silenced it
[Applause]
this is insane they are actually beating
the rocks tigers right now
all these minions are hitting the
voidling still the next time
[Applause]
oh my god they did it
[Applause]
and finally at number one we have the
tragic anime arc of fly
and no tell the esports brotherhood that
fell apart
this is a bitter pill to swallow for og
for their fans in a shock move fly
decided he'd had enough and left with s4
to join eg as they looked to form a new
super team
i felt a new surge of motivation where i
felt like this is really a team
i could win with as opposed to the
previous team where i felt like we kind
of hit a dead end and then i want to win
and i want to do it with teammates i
believe in
for no tale the move wasn't just
business it was
personal when their team needed unity
the most
they have been torn apart and uh well we
just got called into a room
and i learned that the two players are
leaving
and one of them's my best friend like
naruto and sasuke the breakup turned
into a
war but no tail had the last laugh
though as they knocked out eg
and fly from ti-8 on their way to their
first ever
t.i win
[Applause]
sometimes a whole story can be seen in a
handshake
oh gee with the fortitude to stick
through it after dealing with such
importance
all right guys well there you go and now
it's time to be honest with you yeah
it's time to level with you
okay i have never really
properly watched an anime before in my
life
i like the idea of anime don't get me
wrong i like the concept
of anime but not enough to actually sit
down and watch it
am i making a terrible mistake here are
there any animes out there
that you think would change my mind let
me know in the comments section
make sure you subscribe to the score
esports and i'll see you all in the next
one
okay so i see the image i'm gonna guess
that's
from dragon ball z and i'm gonna guess
that is goku i i don't know many of the
names
in in these animes other than the the
main character right so
but you didn't recognize that well this
is what i'm saying i just know that he's
like
he's like yeah you're okay all right
colin i see what you're doing
i see what you're doing